at one point you said you were euphoric
I mean you were even confident that they
didn't have the votes to send you home
how shocked are you to be sitting here
right now as the eliminated House cast
not so shocked I mean
I never read the writing on the thing on
the wall immediately after I realized
that we didn't have the votes so I feel
like I owned it but I worked literally
until the last minute before I sat down
in the nomination chair buy a vote
of nine to one
Nicole you are evicted from the Big
Brother house
do you feel like you were the one being
played at all and if so who do you feel
like the most betrayed by in this game
as far as being betrayed I don't feel
like I was betrayed by anybody I think
that it's the nature of big brother and
I'm a huge fan so I'm all for it I think
I walked into diary room every day and
was just like I'm playing Big Brother
these guys are you know like I'm getting
played or or I was definitely very open
about the fact that like man this really
sucks but I'll take it because I'm here
and it happened because you knew this is
a game like you know how big brother
goes absolutely I mean it's a game I had
so much fun playing it I realized I'm a
little clumsy but we're just gonna take
that with Grace and go with it well
let's talk about Daniel real quick you
know he obviously used The veto putting
you on the Block did you feel like your
best friend there kind of sealed your
fate I could see in your face oh yes
yeah I felt so confident in the people
that were behind us and then realized
that one of those people was not behind
us gonna say at the end of last night's
episode during the end credits Daniel
really separated himself from the rest
of the house guests as they were kind of
celebrating and he even said I should
just pack up my bag so I think he also
realized that he made the wrong move too
did that happen after I walked out the
door or after well yeah yeah
after you walked out the door for sure
but yeah let's talk about some of the
other house guests let's talk about
Taylor because it did feel like you know
she kind of had a Target on her back
from the day she showed up at the house
it seemed like most of the house was
against her she was she was seemingly
being blamed for a lot of different
things why do you think that is jealousy
I don't know
um I think that people get intimidated
by confidence and you know her and I
connected on the first night she was the
first person I had a conversation with
while I'm standing in a porta potty
filled with Blue Goop all over me so you
know I felt a connection there and tried
to push that going forward but when I
was met with you know she's bullying
people and she's saying things now I can
honestly say that I said that I hadn't
experienced any of that side of Taylor
and I never saw that side of Taylor and
then as time went on and people were
telling me there was of of what was
going on and how they were being treated
by her
I was letting that settle in and I I get
very protective over those who feel like
they're they're being I guess you can
say bullied and I was playing this game
and trying to figure out how to navigate
so you said she was bullying people how
so because I feel like the impression
that of America got was that she was the
one being bullied well no I'm saying is
that people were telling me I wasn't I
wasn't witnessing any of it I can in the
beginning I can honestly say like I had
no involvement as far as I didn't have a
problem with her all right and you know
even speaking to Michael week one he's
like I haven't had a problem with her
either and I mean would you say that's
true up until last week because you know
things really did kind of come to a head
and there was that intense kind of
exchange between you Daniel and Taylor I
will never forget what you did in Paloma
you think she didn't spiral because of
you you didn't add to that and now
you're trying to do it to Nicole mind
game
I really do not speak to Nicole like
that ever again what ever again you need
to learn how to speak to people what you
said to me was very passive aggressive
and very rude what was your take on that
whole situation well I can only speak
from my experience with what was going
on and I was going through my own
personal stuff you know my mom's
battling cancer
um I was called into the diary room
upstairs then called to the diary room
downstairs and I'm a huge big brother
fan and I've seen Big Brother house
guests receive bad news
and I thought that I was walking into
the diary room
an envelope sitting on the chair
you know I don't know excuse me I'm
sorry Nicole yeah it's okay I you know I
thought something happened to my mom the
flood of that emotion walking into the
diary room and then questions being
asked of me about Taylor it took over
like those emotions took over and I felt
like I was being cornered and these
questions were being asked of me about
Taylor and I was taking it the way that
it wasn't being presented to me I was
taking it a different way and because of
the nature of what Big Brother is like
things are going things are going things
are going so they asked me to leave the
diary room to kind of take time for
myself but I took it as like I was
getting kicked out of the Diary room and
I wasn't able to you know to vent what I
needed to vent but with that moment also
when I went back into my bedroom and I
started crying I remember thinking like
this game is hard and I didn't know how
to handle those questions about Taylor
because I started realizing that all of
of this negative energy was because I
was letting other people's words cloud
my own judgment and you know I take full
responsibility for that and I wish I
could go back in time and just
continue from week one with Taylor but
you know I was putting myself in a
position of working strategically to
keep her to cover me as the shield and I
thought I could manipulate her I thought
I could control her game we're talking
big brother we're stuck in a house and
we're trying to figure out how to win
how to get to the end and I just tried
to play somebody else's game and I let
it get the best of me it seemed like
Taylor was kind of trying to offer
Support over your mental health and
maybe there was a misunderstanding there
were there like specific comments or
like why did it I guess trigger you so
much and do you regret it what happened
I haven't seen anything that's been
played back I really want to go back and
watch the whole thing I definitely think
I probably no well I know I took her
words and I definitely overreacted but I
also didn't think that it was going to
escalate to where it did especially when
it comes to Daniel those weren't my
intentions at all and you know going
forward I want to be able to look back I
want to be able to reflect and I really
want to be able to learn learn from the
whole situation because I felt like I
was going through something as well and
then everything that just was piling on
top so I just hope going forward that
I'm able to address that with Taylor and
continue addressing those issues with
her because I think that she deserves
that for me and I hope that a lot of the
things that I've said to her over the
last two or three days that were able to
get to that point where we were able to
hold hands in those last moments that we
were in the house together and the words
that we are sharing with each other were
nothing but love and and you know
affectionate words so well you know
because of that fight with you Daniel
and Taylor The Leftovers was formed what
did you make of that Alliance I'm so
proud of them I'm so proud of them I
have to give Michael a lot of credit he
tried throwing a bone to me and I did
not bite because I felt like I was being
betrayed by Monty he sat with me in the
room and he goes Nicole you know I keep
forgetting to remind myself that walking
into this bird brother their house if
you're not part of an alliance of seven
or eight it's probably happening yeah
and it wasn't until after I was on the
Block that I looked back on that
conversation and I said oh I wish I
would have listened a little bit more
carefully we're set on the live feeds
that you're someone who doesn't cause
drama you don't spread rumors you play
honestly you're straightforward now that
you're out of the Big Brother house how
would you describe your gameplay oh my
goodness I told myself going into this
house that I wasn't going to let anybody
else's game Run my game and that's
exactly what I did I let other people's
game get in the way of what my goal was
and I let other people's thoughts of
somebody get in my head and Cloud my
judgment again I take full
responsibility for that for not staying
true to myself it's big brother you know
we're stuck in this house and all I can
say is that I've learned a very valuable
lesson and I want to keep learning from
it and I hope that you know I can
continue to move forward and grow from
it what would you say is your biggest
regret I mean I don't really have any
regrets but I will say I should have
stuck with Michael
[Music]